[inaudible].
All right, so we touched on the first
amendment a little bit in the first half,
but I think there's also just
a fundamental misunderstanding
about what speech
is related to the First Amendment in that
the first amendment basically is about
what the government is not allowed to do.
And people have now extrapolated that to
think it means what everyone can't do.
Can you talk to, is that famous
xkcd comment comic about, uh,
people have the right to tell you
you're an asshole on the internet and it
doesn't violate the first amendment.
And that's true,
although I see it all
day long, I get, yes,
I get that comic thrown at me sometimes
even when it's a government institution
doing the censorship. So it's,
it's overused a little bit too.
And that Kinda just gets
in my craw a little bit.
But the first amendment really only does
protect you from the government and it
doesn't just protect you from Congress
and protects you from the states and
protects you from the mis municipalities.
It protects you from the public
colleges and universities and their
administrators.
Um,
those are all state actors for the First
Amendment when it doesn't protect you
against is your private employer.
Um,
which means that I could well be fired
for anything I say on this show today.
I'll see what I can do. Um, not to
give you an idea is yeah. Uh, you know,
your parents don't, uh, if you say,
I remember her saying free speech to my
parents and I was very young probably
right after I read it about the Skokie
case and my mother giving me a side eye
either probably burn a hole
through my skull at this point. Um,
but you know, it only protects
you against the government.
It doesn't protect you from criticism of
your peers and your contemporaries and
it shouldn't,
you know,
that's kind of part and parcel of having
the public conversation is if you have
a bad idea and you're
out there spouting it,
we all have the right to tell you you
got a shitty idea and we should say that
because otherwise, well we might
see that shitty idea spreading.
And that's kind of the point of,
like we were talking about earlier about
letting these terrible ideas out there
is so that we can stand
up and defeat them. Yeah.
Are you seeing any major threats right
now from the government related to free
speech? Because a lot of times
I'll see people saying, well,
Trump is attacking this, or you
know, he texts journalism a lot now.
It's no secret what my feeling about
the mainstream media is these days.
I mean I think it's largely
just partisan garbage.
I don't think you should be killing these
people are harming these people in any
way.
Just to be very clear,
I hope that by by mocking them
and exposing their nonsense,
we'll get a new generation of better
journalists and people who really live to
the code of trying to find
truth and all of that.
But do you see a direct threat right
now coming from the government,
either from Trump or or elsewhere? There's
always a direct threat yet. I mean,
let's be clear.
People in power will always,
if given the opportunity,
silence their opponents,
they will preserve the status quo.
And it's not just people in power.
It is an entirely human reaction to want
to censor the people we disagree with.
We think we have terrible ideas.
That's kind of a baser
instincts that we all have. Now.
We have to overcome that and understand
the value of, of not doing that, but it's,
it's kind of understandable and weight
and that's why we have to be so vigilant
in protecting free speech
because once the tools are there,
they don't go away.
And we've seen this throughout history
and they are wielded and people laughed
at me when I was talking during the
election cycle to I guess kind of betray
some of my personal political
beliefs. Then, you know,
I was kind of talking about how the
executive branch overreach as many people
did of the last administration
was problematic because you know,
what about the next
guy who comes to power?
Maybe he's going to do something crazy
and nobody, they all laughed at me. Hey,
I was talking about that then I was
talking about it when Bush was doing it.
I was talking about it when Obama was
doing it, and I tell you, he laughed.
And then Donald J.
Trump was elected president.
And I looked at them and I said,
what now?
Uh, and you know, you, you said, oh,
it couldn't be possible that somebody,
we disagree with all that much who we
think is really terrible would ever get
elected president.
And when they started melting
down over the election,
I looked at them and I said,
told yourself,
you can't be forwarded if executive
actions when it's the guy you like,
but then not for them when
it's the guy you don't like,
of course they're all going to do it
if you give them the power to do it.
And it's the same thing with free speech.
And I think what's really important
to remember is that those mechanisms,
there's tools of censorship are never
ever going to run down to the benefit of
the marginalized communities that people
are oftentimes seeking to protect.
It just doesn't happen.
The reason that I'm marginalized is
that they don't have political power.
They're not going to be the
ones implementing these rules.
And that's incredibly problematic
and people don't understand that very
practical reality that those tools of
censorship are going to be used to defend
the status quo, which is what
these people are trying to disrupt.
And disruption is kind of the,
just the major threat that
everyone in power fields.
And we've seen it throughout history,
that they're in the civil rights movement.
When protestors were arrested for sitting
at lunch counters or for engaging in
nonviolent protest,
but were arrested for disorderly
conduct because people reacted to their
protests in violent ways because
there were violent Vicodin thugs.
They were only exonerated
because of the first amendment.
And it took going to the supreme court.
And it's really important to remember,
I mean how many LGBT artists and authors
and publications faced censorship and
had their materials deemed obscenity
at times and not even sent through the
mail. You know, sometimes before you know,
food and preventing them from integrating
into the national consciousness.
I mean it's, it's
really, really important.
So is there something happening right
now via the government that you think
shouldn't be happening? I get
the broad sense, sort of the,
the blue sky version of this that yes,
people in power always are going to want
to maintain power and do what they have
to do to silence people,
etc. But at the college and
university level specifically,
I think a lot of it is coming from um,
the Department of Justice.
Uh,
and the office for civil rights of the
Department of Education a few years back
had an agreement that they
called a blueprint for
sexual harassment policies at
colleges and universities.
And it basically defines sexual harassment
is any unwelcome conduct of a sexual
nature, including verbal conduct,
which we also know as speech. Yeah.
And
the breathtaking broadness of that policy
really kind of spread like wildfire.
Um,
and you know,
these harassment policies have always
kind of been problematic at times.
This is directly tied to
title nine, right? Yes. Yeah.
Okay. And you know, it's,
it's one of the, I don't know if
it's even an unintended consequence.
It might be a very well
unintended consequence, but
you start seeing things at,
for example,
just the number of years back,
there was a student at the University of
Oregon who was sitting on the ledge in
a dorm room window and she saw a couple
outside and as a joke she shouted,
I hit it first,
which I didn't even know what that meant
when it first came in and I had to look
it up and realize that
it was about Rayjay. Uh,
having sex with Kim Kardashian and Kanye.
I guess that's a thing people care
about nowadays. I don't know, you know,
behind the, he is the leader of the
free speech movement now. So boy,
maybe I do need to find another job.
But anyways,
that the couple was offended and ran
upstairs and talk to the Ra and this
student was hit with several disciplinary
charges including sexual harassment.
First just shouting.
I hit it first.
And this is because of the latitude
that these laws gave colleges too.
Once, you know, department
of Education said,
this is what we consider
sexual harassment.
No College University administrator in
the right mind is going to look at that
and say, oh, we'll just ignore that.
They're going to write new
policies because they don't
want huge investigations
that costs a lot of money,
take a lot of time,
and have ultimately the potential to cost
the school all of its federal funding
when it comes down to it.
So we've seen the proliferation
of these really broad policies,
some of which have hilarious lists of
examples of things that could constitute
sexual harassment,
like inappropriately directed laughter,
elevator eyes is another fire fame for it.
These are all things that
are known as flirting,
recording or whatever you want to call it.
I'm sure there's a whole their term,
but like that's how you meet people.
And sometimes it really is,
and honestly it's the sexual
harassment angle has become a broader
discriminatory harassment angle because
a lot of these policies start to look
the same based on any protected class.
And so when you say that,
you know,
any unwelcome comment based on
a protected class, you know,
and that's drawing from a
particular policy or anything
is harass discriminatory
harassment.
Well that's a big problem because
that cuts off subjectively,
whichever way you go. Basically half
of a debate, people for instance,
on different sides of affirmative action
are both going to find their opponents
ideology probably offensive.
Of course,
if you are against affirmative action
for whatever reason, you might be, uh,
people who support affirmative action,
they're going to say,
well that is discriminatory based on a
protected class race and they shouldn't
be allowed to say that.
And yet we've seen students hosting events
like affirmative action bake sales to
kind of make a point about what they
think is the unfairness and affirmative
action.
And administrators have tried to shut
them down and sometimes have succeeded and
shutting them down. Uh, and you know,
I can give you countless examples
of things just like that,
but it's dangerous because it kind of
creates an orthodoxy of what we're allowed
to say, what we're allowed
to think. And you know,
there is no position in that.
I can think of that.
And I can say actually I think there is
no position that shouldn't be subject to
challenge.
There is nothing that
shouldn't be susceptible to
somebody disagreeing with it
in a public way and
starting that conversation.
Nobody has the right to
declare this is how it is.
That is,
I guess our collective to circle
all the way back to the beginning.
It's our collective right to participate
in that decision of what we believe.
Yeah,
and that's why I have such the problem
with this related to the way that the
modern left bules with these things.
Because if you're going to say, all right,
we're not going to draw
cartoons about certain things.
Now I'm not saying you should go
out of your way to offend people,
but once you say we're going to
allow certain things not to be done,
you've handed all of your faculty,
all of your power,
all of your decision making capability
over to a certain set of people.
It doesn't matter what those,
what those people believe in or are.
But then it's like,
well then they know,
well we got them with something and we
can just keep going and going and going.
And before you know it, you know it's
too late to, to fight back. I mean,
and again, it's going to backfire. It's
going to backfire against the people. And,
and I think that you see
it backfiring sometimes.
You look at the faculty members recently
who have been targeted by outrage mobs
and people calling for their heads or
their jobs or sometimes both. Yeah. Um,
and they, sometimes when, by the
way, and my good friend Brett wines,
then it still does not have a job.
Just recently for more striking example
even is a Fresno state ran to Gerard
treated,
you know,
some intemperate and not particularly
polite things about Barbara Bush right
after she died. Um, and you're being very
kind and she can do whatever she wants.
But yeah,
it was pretty nasty stuff.
My mother told me never to speak ill of
the dead and so, you know, I don't know.
I don't know. No, I mean
you were being nice to,
to what was tweeted feelings on here and
it was the right that was calling for
her head and we, I mean, one of my
colleagues, I felt really bad. I was,
I was the one who helped write the letter,
but he was the one who wrote our
public facing blog post on the website.
He was getting hate mail and probably
still is getting hate mail from people
saying, how could you defend this woman?
How could you, I mean, it goes both ways.
Everyone's going to sense try
and censor their opponent.
So just really be careful. Right.
Well, I'm glad you brought that one up.
So basically this, this woman
who's, she's a professor, right?
She tweeted some really nasty stuff about
Barbara Bush who had just died and by,
by every account,
Barbara Bush was a totally decent woman,
but that's actually irrelevant for this.
And yes.
Then the right started screaming and oh,
she should be fired. She should be fired.
She was not fired. The Fresno
state. She's still there. Um,
I thought, wow, this is an exact example
of how free speech is supposed to work.
She said what she wanted people
mocked her or supported her.
The university decided to make a
decision. Now, it's interesting.
If the university had fired her,
let's say they had said,
these ideas are beyond the pale,
and then people started digging into some
other things that she's said that are,
that are pretty radical.
If that had happened,
would you guys have offered her defense?
Because doesn't the university have
the right to make the decisions that it
wants? I don't know what their
policies are on on tenure, for example,
or that sort of thing,
but don't they have the right to employ
people that they want to be employed or
not?
Not that I want to give that power to
the mob because we know that the mob does
awful things. It depends when
the government as an employer,
the government actually is
restricted in what it can do for a,
an with her spot respect to an
employees off duty speech when a,
and I think that's particularly important
with faculty members who are supposed
to be public intellectuals.
They're supposed to be out there and kind
of discussing and debating and this is
what we expect out of faculty
members at colleges and universities.
But when the government is the employer
and the speeches made as a private
citizen on a matter of public concern
is this very clearly was then the
government has to make a pretty high
showing that that speech so materially
interferes with the provision of services
that the government is involved in,
that it warrants overcoming the employer
employees first amendment rights.
And we actually wrote a long letter
and was co-signed they by the Aclu of
Northern California,
uh,
the electronic frontier foundation
and a whole bunch of other, uh,
organizations and on dryers
behalf and sent it in.
Incidentally, shortly after
they got our letter, the,
a university issued their statement that
they weren't going to discipline her.
Right.
So you are making the distinction in
this case that because this was not on
campus, this wasn't being in a class,
you know, taught in the class or,
or brainwashing students in the class
name that's different what she's doing on
her private side. And especially because
as you said, as a public intellectual,
you're supposed to be talking about stuff
that that's different than perhaps if
she had said these very
same things in class,
they could have taken a different stance
that maybe would've had a little more
legal positioning.
Is that fair to say?
That's where it gets tricky
because there's a circumstance. Um,
the Supreme Court,
uh,
back in 2006 held that speech
made pursuant to official
job duties is basically
speech that's commissioned by the
government and therefore it does not have
first amendment protection.
You can be fired for it,
but they did not decide whether or not
that would relate to speech that relates
to scholarship or teaching,
uh, as a supreme court put it,
which is due to the special concern about
academic freedom that we have for the
reasons of faculty members
being public intellectuals.
The Fourth Circuit and the ninth circuit
or California's have both said that no,
this ruling,
that speech pursuant to official job
duties does not apply at colleges and
universities, uh, to speech that
relates to scholarship or teaching.
So in California she could
have been protected either way,
but it's not that way
all around the country.
Some courts have declined to find that
exception to the 2006 Garcetti ruling.
Um, others have kind of
ignored it for the time being.
So one of these days the supreme court's
probably going to have to make another
decision on that. Yeah. I'm curious,
I know you guys are a
nonpartisan organization,
but if these decisions
were left up to the states,
do you guys have a position
on that in and of itself?
I'm sure you have a personal position,
but does fire have a position on that?
I mean,
I think our,
our position is that the exception for
scholarship or teaching absolutely should
be applied across the country.
It's really fundamentally important for
faculty members to be able to conduct,
you know, controversial, disruptive, you
know, as it relates to the status quo.
Research and writing without fearing
for their jobs because that's how we're
going to get new ideas.
If you just talk about things that
aren't going to rock the boat,
if you just research things that
we're never going to get anywhere
you, you need the bomb throwers. Yeah,
there's room for that.
So what about cases where,
and I guess this brings up a little bit
related to tenure because I think there
is something interesting because
it's funny, I hear from professors,
I get a ton of emails from professors
saying that they love what we're doing
here and that they are afraid sometimes
tenured professors are still afraid of
the mob. They know they're not going to
get fired, but they're afraid of the mob.
Is there an inherent problem in tenure
in a way now? Because you could,
if you have that protection, and I'm
all for saying whatever you want to say,
that technically if you were
a history history professor,
let's say you could start,
you could just start losing your
mind and teaching really dishonest,
complete reversal of the truth stuff.
Um,
and have the protection of not being
fired like that actually handicaps the
pursuit of knowledge from, from
the university, doesn't it?
I'm not terribly concerned about
that because generally speaking,
there are ways for faculty
to be disciplined or are
removed even with tenure,
oftentimes for gross professional,
you know, competency issues.
Um, you know, if you are, say,
teaching math and you're teaching
students that two plus two is 17,
I think that's in common core.
You can,
there's ways that the university can
address that and that's not really what
we're seeing. What we're seeing
more often as a, for instance,
the professor who's teaching physics,
who is on the side of the Holocaust
Denier, uh, and he's, you know,
maybe not necessarily
teaching that in class,
but does that have any ramifications
for his ability to teach physics?
Probably not.
Um,
that's not a competency competency to
teach the topic that you were hired to
teach things.
But if it leaked into the classroom then
that then it's a separate issue. That's,
well,
if you are teaching a class on physics
and find some occasion to talk about the
Holocaust,
I think you're probably not teaching the
thing that you are hired to do and then
it's up to the school to
decide what to do. Yeah,
that's a different problem I think.
Um,
I think that that indicates pretty
squarely along with the denial of the
Holocaust happened that you are
in fact losing your mind. Right.
So what are some of the cases may be one
or two cases that you guys are working
on right now or that you have your
eye on right now that you think are
particularly relevant that
people should know about? Well,
we just issued a press release
this morning. In fact, uh,
just Amir hour or two before I came here,
uh,
at Syracuse University where we sent
a letter on Friday. Uh, this one is,
it's just bananas. Yeah. Let me pause
you for a second. I haven't read it yet,
but I wanted to go to Syracuse to be in
broadcasting because I wanted to be like
a news anchor or a or a sports center
anchor road. I really want it to be,
but there are big broadcasting school,
so I'm already fascinated by
this as a place that's, you know,
about disseminating information. Well,
you might be glad you didn't hear this.
Here we go.
A fraternity had an event every year where
the pledges or new members would come
in.
It was a private event and they would do
skits that roasted the other members of
the fraternity. A lot of fraternities
have this kind of tradition. Um,
I'm pretty sure that minded.
But they went through some
skits and one of them,
for example,
was making fun of a member of the
fraternity who was a known and vocal Trump
supporter and conservative.
So they satirized him by having somebody
who is supposed to be him starting as
rival fraternity.
That was quote unquote a white empire.
And to join people had to take a
horrifically racist, antisemitic, uh,
oath and sounds like it's all in good fun.
Well,
whatever. May Be tasteless, but all
in good fun. You know what they're,
they're satirizing and it's no different
than you see comedians doing all the
time on a stage. Satirizing people.
Yeah. Uh, another one was, uh,
they Saturdays,
one of their brothers for being
chronically whipped by his girlfriend and
portrayed him as a mentally retarded
and they had him in a wheelchair and all
that stuff and this was
all on a private event.
And you hear the laughter in the
audience indicated that nobody was really
offended by it. They understood this
is kind of just poking fun at people.
The problem is that videos of it leaked
and the student newspaper published them,
which you know, they have the right to
do as well. You can't begrudge them that.
And of course,
as you might imagine,
outrage erupted and the,
within a matter of days the fraternity
had been expelled permanently from
campus.
18 students have been charged
with disciplinary conduct
or business disciplinary
code violations and they're
being threatened with
suspension or expulsion. Uh,
and this is like all right before finals.
And meanwhile a,
an adjunct faculty member had the
gall to express concern about how the
university was handling all of this
and they immediately told them, uh,
because you've used don't align with ours,
you are no longer qualified to teach
at Syracuse University unbelief.
And it's incredibly author authoritarian
sounding. I mean, they are,
they're just reeling to steamroll over
anybody who gets in their way in pursuit
of really just giving somebody a head on
a pike so that the crowd is mollified,
you know, it's, I mean, it's nuts.
They've charged them with, uh,
sexual harassment,
discriminatory harassment. Uh,
nevermind the fact that nobody who the
speech was actually intended for actually
was offended by it.
It didn't,
it's not their fault. You know,
they don't know how the videos lead.
They are posting to a private Facebook
page and somebody must've had to
somebody's computer or
something like that.
But the speech was purely private
and nobody was offended by it.
And if every conversation between
two students can be the grounds for
disciplinary investigation because a
third party later found out what was said
during that conversation. Well,
um, we'd all be in jail. Yeah,
exactly. It reduces free
speech to a complete melody.
It's crazy. Uh, and you know, it's just,
it's really,
it's galling and be just
really harsh and punitive, uh,
bent of the, of the university and
all of this is mystifying. Wait,
so just on the technical side now,
because this is something good
that Trump's done related to this,
because he got rid of a lot of the title
nine expansions and all that and device
and they got rid of that stuff, which I
assume you agree with, right? Basically.
I mean, it's stuff that we had spent a
lot of time fighting against. Right. Okay.
So Obama expanded at Trump,
got rid of it.
I think for the nae in
the name of free speech,
when you hear stories of like Laura Kipnis
who I've had on and and many others,
the witch hunts that
happen that are crazy.
So these policies that they're
saying that these students violated,
these have nothing to do with
government policies, right? These,
they're saying they violated
school policies, is that correct?
I just want to be clear.
They're discriminatory harassment policies
are obviously drawn on a lot of the
same language because they receive
federal money in the form of student loans
and things like that. So they actually
still have to adhere to title nine,
even though they're not a
state institution, obviously.
Um, but you know, they,
they've been charged with this
laundry list of offenses. Uh, they've,
the administration has been rushing
through trying to kind of get the process
over with as soon as possible.
Meanwhile,
not giving them really a lot of details
until just recently in terms of what the
charges are based on and,
and all of this. I mean,
it's very clearly a steam
rolling and, uh, it's,
it's outrageous. Uh, and you know,
that's kind of the most recent thing.
So tell me a little bit about how you
guys get involved in that. So, okay,
so you issue a press statement
now or a press release.
Now they know they have a
little bit of public defense.
Do you guys actually
work with the students?
Like just kind of lay out how that
whole process goes? Yeah, so, uh,
on our website we have a, a format
anyone can fill out to request help.
And me and my team every morning we'll
go through the case submissions and,
uh, we'll review them and,
you know, follow up for more
documentation if necessary.
And like I said, we get damn near close
to a thousand of them a year now, uh,
which is a lot of work.
Um,
and we investigate and develop the cases
and figure out what the best situation,
you know, the best possible
tactics in each case would be. Um,
usually the next step involves writing
a letter telling the university which in
Syracuse case we sent out on
Friday, uh, telling them, hey,
this is the applicable law,
are these the,
the political applicable norms that you
should be adhering to as though college,
um, and here's why what you're doing
has run a fall of all of that. Um,
generally speaking, you know,
we'll wait for a response, uh,
in good faith,
given the university some time
to acknowledge our concerns
and work through them.
And, you know, otherwise
we will, excuse me,
issue a press release and start bringing
public pressure to bear sometimes in
public college and university cases.
We'll take it to litigation if we have to.
Not every case, obviously,
because you know, there's a
range of cases that are, uh,
you know,
make for a good lawsuit.
But even just recently filed the
lawsuit of Joliet Junior College,
and this is kind of again,
kind of flips the narrative a little bit
because it was a students who saw, uh,
people,
uh,
basically talking about how capitalism
is great and decided that she wanted to
make a good point about socialism.
So she handed out, you know,
and distributed flyers about how, you
know, they said shutdown capitalism,
inviting people to like a
workshop, uh, about socialism.
This was actually not far from where
I live in Chicago's and Joliet junior
college.
And she was actually confronted
by a number of campus
police officers who pulled
her into an interrogation room,
demanded to examine the flyers and
then confiscated them and saying,
you can't do that here. You know, the, the
political climate, you know right now is,
you know,
might start something.
I'm actually shocked to hear it happening
that the story is not the reverse big.
This is an odd one. I'm glad you used
it as an example. Actually, you know,
it goes to show, I actually, you know,
you'll be interested to hear this. I, my,
my team and I actually did a really a
quick analysis and this isn't scientific
or anything of all the
public cases that we've, uh,
have on our website from the
beginning of fires history.
And actually more than half of them
have nothing to do with politics.
More than half of them are simply
administrators having power again and when
they have the power that will use it
to regulate or silence speech that they
find in convenient or critical of
the university or administrators or,
or just kind of not nice.
Generally less than half of our cases
had to do with speakers being silenced
specifically because of the viewpoint
they were espousing. On a political level.
It's, you know, it kind of
undoes a lot of the narrative.
And to be honest, I'm kind of a
little bit tired of the whole,
whether the right or left love censorship,
more argument.
I think it's completely unproductive
and does nothing to solve the problem,
which is we all need to understand why
protecting free speech is important.
I'd much rather focus my
time there. Um, and you know,
so it's really that whole narrative can,
could use a little deconstructing for a
little bit. And I'm glad that, you know,
we had that case that kind of allowed us
to, to show it and people appreciate it.
I got a lot of messages from people
on the right who said, you know,
I disagree with everything that
that young woman had to say.
Uh, and I would sit there and
I would yell that in her face,
but you know what? I'm damn glad you guys
stood up for her rights. And you know,
when I get messages like that,
it just,
it warms my heart and I get
them from people on both
sides saying, you know what,
I probably wouldn't have reacted in the
same way you did leaping to a defense of
free speech. But I'm glad you did it
because I got something out of that.
You know, it made me think about
why my reaction wasn't that. Uh,
and if I, if I get, if I
can elicit that in people,
I feel great about my day. That's
the heavy lifting I think. Well,
that's a beautiful thing and that's
why I did what you guys are doing. Uh,
the final thing I want to mention is that
I just remembered in this last moment
that the reason that you're here,
I,
so I had wanted to have one of you guys
on for about a year or so and you've
been on our,
our master list of all this.
And then I think about
three months or so ago,
someone tweeted at me that they
were at school, at school library,
and they were watching a
video of me and Ben Shapiro,
and that they were reported to the,
either the diversity office or one of
these things that it was hate speech and
that another student shouldn't be allowed
to, to watch these, these evil things,
et Cetera, et cetera. It turns
out that this was in the UK,
so it was not under the jurisdiction
that you guys, uh, cover,
which obviously is the United States.
Um, but it just shows that this thing,
this monster that we're fighting
is not local to us here in America.
It's all over the world.
And there are other organizations like
fire that do this work. And uh, yeah.
And although it's depressing to know
that somebody is being reported for
watching a video that I put out there,
it's good to know that you
guys all came to the rush.
You all came to the defense
and you were like, who is it?
Can we connect with them? You know, I
connected them with some of your people.
I think, and maybe you've passed them on,
so I connected them with spikes. Okay.
So there is over there.
Yeah it is. And you know,
you see it happening in Canada all
the time. The UK, I mean you can,
I have Google alerts set and every,
no,
I wouldn't say every morning cause
it's more like 40,000 times a day.
I get emails from Google with the latest
headlines about free speech and it's
not just even the UK and Canada.
There are students protesting in India
about freedom of speech issues and all
kinds of countries. Australia, it's a big
conversation right now. This is, you know,
it's just not limited to here.
It's not limited to anywhere. This,
the idea that college
campuses are kind of a,
both a microcosm of society and
a training ground and an night,
a place where the ideas of the country,
uh, kind of come from in a large sense.
That's kind of a global concept.
I don't think that's limited to
higher education in the United States.
And you know,
it's,
I really hope that we can
convince students that that's
where the safeguarding,
uh, it's, it's too important
not to. Well said, my friend,
I'm with Ya. And for more on the fine work
that Ari and the fire folks are doing,
checkout the fire.org.